Aristotle and Plato,
our main Greek boys knew what they were talking about
when they thought about love. In fact
Canadian psychologist, John Allen Lee also
found their work meaningful, that he borrowed some of their greek terms
and invented the colour wheel theory of love.
Vibrant and easy to follow, we will also be using
this tool throughout this video to help
to help you explore the many different types of love.
Although times have changed since Aristotle and Plato
were alive, the world has evolved with dating apps
flirty emojis and romantic means
one thing hasn't; We all yearn for affection.
Whether you're just getting into your first relationship, or you
prioritize self-love first and foremost,
here are the 8 types of love you will experience in this lifetime.
1) Playful love; Ludus
Are you a 'no-strings-attached' sort of partner?
Do others find you flirty and fun? Then
Ludus describes you perfectly. People
who experience playful love see it as one big
exciting game. Instead of committing fully to
one person, their main objective
is to make things less complicated by having multiple partners
or being friends with benefits. On
the upside, this type of love keeps things burning
with excitement and childlike innocence.
But on the downside, people who
prefer playful love like to feel in control, so they
end up manipulating their partners, whether it means lying,
deceiving or exploiting their weak spots.
Unfortunately, if you're a highly sensitive person,
then this type of love may not be for you.
Daniel Kim, from We The Kims channel,
dives deep into what a highly sensitive person is,
and how they function differently.
Be sure to check out his link in the description below after this video.
2) Obsessive love; Mania
Ah yes, there's nothing like being bitten
by the nasty old green bug, or
putting on a mad hat. People who experience Mania
often suffer from low self esteem,
and want to feel complete. So they
often latch onto their partner, which usually creates a
codependent relationship. The good news however
is that one can always grow out of Mania,
and move onto a different type of love that's free from obsession.
In order to repair a codependent relationship,
Dr Misty Hook says that it's important to
set boundaries and find happiness as and individual.
Whether that means spending more time with family and friends,
broadening your networking circle,
or picking up a new hobby, these activities can all build
your independence.
3) Erotic love; Eros
Eros was the son of Aphrodite, the goddess
of love. This is when things get real steamy
and intense, like those R rated scenes your
parents stop you from watching. This type of relationship
involves a strong physical and emotional connection,
where both partners exercise compassion.
Romantic and idealistic,
Eros leaves people feeling high on love.
It is also often the initial stage of an exclusive relationship.
4) Enduring love; Pragma
Do you often feel like butterflies are overrated?
Or just want something that's stable and lasting.
People who prefer enduring love have a practical
approach towards relationships. They choose convenience
over romance and are more concerned about whether
a partner can bring common sense to the table.
The individual also find their partner's level of education,
religious beliefs, social status and financial
standing important.
5) Friendship love; Philia
This type of love, along with the remainder, are not
in Lee's colour wheel theory of love,
but they are still important enough to the Greeks to be explored.
In fact, they consider it far superior than Eros
because it's a love that's equal.
It is commonly believed that if you have one good
friend in life, then you're lucky. Philia
is the platonic love we have for others whom we are
not physically attracted to. This type of love
thrives on components of loyalty, openness
and a true sense of understanding one another.
6) Familial love; Storge
Storge is a Greek
term that means natural affection or family love.
This type of love is the first you experience throughout your
life. It forms between parents and their children.
Some of us are blessed with wonderful childhoods,
and we can rely on our parents again and again for
guidance. But those of us who grew up in a toxic household
may find it difficult to achieve familial love.
7) Self-love; Philautia
this type of love shares the Buddhist philosophy
of self-compassion.
In order to reach Philautia, one must exercise self
understanding, until they gain the strength
to love themselves. It is only
until we accept who we are that we can love others.
But, true self-love isn't just
experience at certain moments. It must be
unconditional love you have for yourself.
If you've been in an abusive household or relationship,
self-love will seem like a foreign concept.
Some helpful tips that are to practice include:
Asking yourself what you need, allowing yourself to feel
your emotions instead of tuning them out,
and meditating.
8) Selfless love; Agape
Lat but not least, we have Agape.
This is the highest form of love we will ever experience.
Agape is what Buddhists refer to as universal
kindness. When we exercise selfless love,
we are capable in forgiving and seeing the good in others.
You can have Agape for strangers,
religious figures or nature. In this
type of love, you learn to be altruistic
and giving, helping those in great need of support.
Which type of love resonates with you the most?
And which kind would you liek to experience
before you die? Please share your thoughts with us below
If you're curious to learn more about love, be sure to check
out our video on Sternberg's theory of love
Also, don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for more helpful tips, and share this video with
others. With your help, we can reach more people
and provide our support. Thanks for watching!